und wir wechseln das Thema und schauen
auf den grausamen vergewaltigungstod der
13-Jährigen Leonie sie wird mit mehreren
Ecstasy-Tabletten außer Gefecht gesetzt
mehrfach von drei Männern vergewaltigt
und schließlich erstickt sie an ihrer
Überdosis danach wird sie tot an einen
Baum gelehnt
13 Jahre alt Tod abgelegt angelehnt an
einen Baum einer der Angeklagten ist zu
bei wie eine Trophäe hatte er monatelang
noch ein Video von der Tat auf seinem
Handy das Leonie erst 11 war will er
nicht gewusst haben sie habe älter
gewirkt sich als 18 ausgegeben außerdem
habe er das Mädchen für eine
Prostituierte gehalten ihr 50 Euro für
den Geschlechtsverkehr bezahlt mit
Ecstasy-Tabletten in einem Becher mit
Eistee betäubt wehrlos und willenlos
wird das Mädchen Überstunden missbraucht
der mit Angeklagte ramesch behauptet in
einer Beziehung mit Leonie gewesen zu
sein die beiden hätten zuvor bereits
sexuelle Kontakte gehabt von den jetzt
Angeklagten drei jungen Männern aus
Afghanistan hatten sich zwei noch am
Tatort als Ersthelfer ausgegeben zu bei
einer der Haupttäter setzte sich nach
davon ab er wurde im März ausgeliefert
[Musik]
Tag 2 also im Prozess der Schande
Bildreporter Jörg völkerling ist für
Bild in Wien wie geht es heute im
Prozess weiter Jörg
ja mit der Aussage des zweiten
Angeklagten des Inhabers der Wohnungen
der diese schreckliche Tat geschah und
da war eigentlich für heute ein
Geständnis angekündigt worden aber da
hat seinen Verteidiger Verteidiger von
Hatschi offenbar was falsch verstanden
das kann auch daran gelegen haben dass
erst einen Tag vor dem Verfahren in
diesen Prozess reinkam vier Anwälte
haben schon dass Mandat hingeworfen weil
sie so angefeindet worden sind dass sie
überhaupt diese acht Afghanen vertreten
und jetzt hat der Hatschi sozusagen seit
zwei Stunden erzählte hier was vom Pferd
man kann es nicht anders sagen und ich
bin ehrlich auch ein bisschen empört
weil nicht nur diese Tat an sich macht
fassungslos sondern auch immer wieder
dieses einlassungsverhalten von
den Angeklagten die wirklich keinerlei
Schuld bei sich sehen sondern immer nur
die Schuld beim Opfer bei der Frau und
das ging jetzt hier quasi im Überstunden
so dass er sagte er sei am Morgen erst
aufgewacht da sei alles schon zu spät
gewesen dann fragt die Richterin ja
hatten sie Kontakt zu Leonie ja die kam
irgendwann und hätte bei ihm schlafen
wollen fragt die Richterin ja wollte sie
Sex nein nein die wollte nur kuscheln
dann hätten sie ineinander einander
geschmückt zusammen gelegen man fragt
die Richterin ja wie kommt dann aber die
DNA von Leno i Leonie jetzt wird's eklig
auf ihren peniskranz er sagte ja
vielleicht vom umarmen durch die
Unterhose fragt die Richterin vollkommen
fassungslos dann ob er selber Extasy
genommen habe nein habe er nie genommen
ja wie das dann zu seinen drei
Vorstrafen passen ja er hatte mal
Schwierigkeiten musste für seine Eltern
Cannabis verkaufen so geht das jetzt
hier hin und her und in ein paar nehmung
hatte er noch gesagt Leonie seine
[ __ ] gewesen die sich prostituiert
habe die von zu Hause weg genau laufen
seien selber schuld an ihrem Tod sei das
sagt er jetzt das habe er nur gesagt
weil er so panisch gewesen sei über
ihren Tod da passt einfach hinten und
vorne gar nichts zusammen
Jörg also erschreckende Details die die
Angeklagten da versuchen zu erzählen um
sich rauszuwinden um die Schuld von sich
zu weisen wie nimmt die Familie von
Leonie diesen Prozess war
ich halte die aus Nürnberg stammende
Mutter von Leonie hat ja den gesamten
Akt die gesamten Vernehmung alles schon
gelesen weil die sagt sie muss Klarheit
haben sie wollte einfach wissen was für
Abartigkeiten passiert sind aber wir
sagen hat selber auch gesagt ein
Gespräch mit einheimischen Journalisten
sie dachte sie kennt alles in
Abartigkeiten aber das was ihre Tochter
da wieder fahren ist das hat noch mal
alles übertroffen die Familie hat keine
Kraft an diesem Prozess hier
teilzunehmen sie ist an einem der
kommenden prozessstage als Zeugen
geladen und das wird ein verdammt
schwerer Gang dann den Angeklagten hier
in die Augen sehen zu müssen vielleicht
erbarmt sich die Richterin und sagt noch
sie schließt die Angeklagten für die
Dauer der Aussage der Mutter aus weil
das ist fast übermenschlich was man von
ihrer verlangen würde
ja völkerling herzlichen Dank live aus
Wien zum Prozess um die ermordete Leonie
[Musik]